I’m giving the perfect devil fruit to each
straw hat. I saw that my friend Zack over
on his channel Im D. King tried to figure
out the best fruit for each straw hat that
doesn’t have one already. Which sounded
like a ton of fun, so I’m going to be doing
the same thing, but this time, not only will
i try to find even better fruits, but I will
also upgrade the fruits of those straw hats
who already have eaten a fruit. All of these
are going to be absolutely broken.
Starting with Sanji. Now, Zack ended up giving
Sanji Whitebeard’s earthquake fruit, which
would turn Sanji’s kicks into some of the
most devastating attacks in One PIece. No
doubt a great pick. Definitely better than
what Oda, the author of one piece, proposed
for Sanji’s devil fruit: Senor Pink’s
swim swim fruit, which allows the user to***swim***
in the ground or walls. Which is powerful,
but doesn’t fit Sanji’s fighting style
or personality at all. Let’s find him something
that will actually work with his powers. Sanji’s
broad range of abilities actually rule out
a ton of fruits. He can already fly and has
superhuman strength, which means he doesn’t
need any type of Zoan fruit that gives him
those abilities, like Kaido’s Dragon fruit.
He also has fire powers, in my opinion ruling
out something like the magma or fire logia
fruits, that would be redundant. And his genetically
modified body gives him iron hard skin and
high defense values. So sanji doesn’t need
anything like the barrier or diamond fruit
either. I think that one fruit that would
perfectly enhance Sanji’s powers is actually
Aokiji’s ice fruit. A logia type devil fruit
would make sanji even more unpredictable and
harder to damage than before. Ice powers would
be the perfect balance to his fire powers,
making him the Todoroki of One Piece. And
he can use the cold to keep food on the thousand
sunny fresh as well. More balanced than the
earthquake fruit i thought, that has pretty
high collateral damage. But then it hit me.
There is one fruit that’s even better for
Sanji. And that’s Robin’s hana hana no
mi, which would allow Sanji to kick from wherever
with countless legs, make clones of himself
that double all his abilities and just imagine
Sanji making a giant leg, like Robin, but
using his fire abilities with it. And it would
of course also be extremely useful for cooking
abilities.
Next up we have Jinbei. Zack gave him the
mythical buddah fruit, wielded by Fleet admiral
Sengoku. A strong pick, let’s see if we
can improve on that. To pick the right fruit
for him, t’s important to remember that
Jinbei eating a devil fruit would mean that
he is a fishman that can’t swim anymore.
So his fruit would have to be strong enough
to make up for that. And coincidentally, Oda
just gave the perfect answer to this dilemma
in the Manga, where he introduced Jinbei’s
cyborg clone that was created by the Government.
This clone has eaten the Swim Swim fruit that
Oda suggested for Sanji. But in Jinbei’s
case it makes perfect sense. This fruit allows
Jinbei to use his fishman abilities on land.
He can swim and dive on land at incredible
speeds and even use his fishman karate, which
is able to manipulate liquids. I would go
so far as to say that this is the only fruit
that actualy makes sense for Jinbei, if we
want to respect his actual powers in the story.
But let’s move on to Franky. Oda gave Franky
the Arms Arms fruit, that would enable him
to turn any part of his body into a weapon,
fitting for a cyborg who can already turn
parts of his body into weapons. Now that would
be convenient for Franky, but i honestly don’t
think that a lack of weapons is a problem
for him. If anything Franky is such a great
engineer that he can add those himself. After
all he already has integrated parts of Kizaru’s
lazer powers into his body, on top of tons
of other weapons. Zack gave him the Gasha
Gasha fruit, which is a non canon fruit, wielded
by Douglas Bullet, that allows the user to
dismantle anything and erasable it into whatever
they want. Which I can’t lie, is perfect
for Franky and his engineering powers. Since
he knows the plans of the pluton, he could
even use this fruit to reassemble the ancient
weapon. But let’s try to stay within the
canon. One interesting power for Franky could
be Bartolomeos barrier fruit, that would give
him incredible defensive powers and make him
even more tanky than he already is. But i
want to go more into the offensive route.
Something like Buggy’s Bara Bara no mi would
allow him to manipulate his cybord body freely.
And this could be improved by giving him Kid’s
Magnet fruit, that would give Franky similar
powers to Bullet’s non canon fruit. Where
he could use the metal in his surroundings
to upgrade and repair his body or freely assemble
any machine he wishes. But I think I found
one fruit that I think is the absoute perfect
match for franky. Given that Franky’s bottleneck
is his Cola power, that can run out fairly
quickly, Franky would be truly unstoppable
with Enel’s Goro Goro no mi. This would
give him infinite energy to power truly gigantic
machines and also give him incredible offensive
powers. He could turn the Thousand Sunny into
an indestructible force of nature. And, since
we just learned in the Manga, that Vegapunk’s
technology is reverse engineered from the
ancient kingdom’s, that also had unlimited
energy, in my opinion it would make Franky
the most powerful person in the world. So
make sure that you’re subscribed or I will
send Thunder God Franky to get you.
now that of course means that it can’t be
the fruit that we give Nami. By the way that
is exactly the fruit that both Zack and also
Oda would give her. And yes, it seems like
the perfect fit for Nami’s current powers.
But not only do I think that this powerful
fruit is a way better fit for Franky, as I
just explained, but I similar to Sanji and
his fire powers, I do think that it would
be very redundant for Nami. having the Goro
Goro no mi would mean that Nami would need
neither her climat tact nor Zeus anymore,
which both have given her immense offensive
powers. So instead of upgrading something
she already has, I would rather find a devil
fruit that actually enhances her current abilities.
Thinking a bit out of the box, one overpowered
fruit, that I think would make Nami incredibly
powerful and work well with her fighting style
could be Doflamingo’s Ito Ito no mi. Using
her mirages to confuse her opponent, and then
trapping them with her strings would be super
cool to see. She could make clones of herself,
which would give her even more defensive powers
and she could fix things on board of the ship
and give first aid. But I do agree that Nami
could use something that goes with her weather
theme. If Luffy’s father Dragon actually
has something like the storm storm fruit,
that would of course be the ultimate fit for
nami, but it’s not confirmed, so we can’t
use it. A much better fit, instead could be
Big Mom’s soul soul fruit. Nami already
is using a homie to fight, and if she was
able to turn anything from lightning to fire
to water into a living thing that she can
control, she could manipulate the weather
and much much more. And other than Big Mom,
Nami would probably only use her own soul
and maybe that of her crew mates to create
homies. But my personal favorite and in my
opinion the perfect fruit for Nami, would
be Kaido’s Dragon fruit. It can naturally
create clouds in just moments, which would
turn the entire battle field into her terrain
where she could rain down lightning with zeus.
She could create wind for the sunny. Of course
she could fly and on top of everything have
the most ridiculous offensive power imaginable.
Zack gave this fruit to Usopp instead. Or
to be more precise, to Usopp’s sling shot.
Which I find incredibly creative and would
look pretty epic, but again, we want to try
and work with the Straw hat’s natural abilities.
Oda’s pick for Usopp is the Pocket Pocket
Fruit which would endow his body with infinite
pockets, perfect for a sniper like him who
needs places to store his ammo, which…i
gotta be honest is pretty lame i feel. In
my opinion the only devil fruit that I want
for Usopp is a mythical human fruit, model
Giant. Usopp throughout the story has become
friends with the Giants of Elbaf. Dorry and
Broggy, Oimo and Kashi, Hairujin on Dressrosa.
The giants represent Usopp’s image of a
brave warrior of the sea. Usopp’s dream.
So really, what better way to make his dream
come true, than turning him into an actual
giant. This devil fruit clearly must exist
in One Piece. And it would be so perfect for
Usopp. But since it’s not official yet,
let’s think of a suitable alternative. Viola’s
giro grio fruit would allow him to target
enemies far far away, but having awakened
his observation haki on Dressrosa, i don’t
think he needs that anymore honestly. Instead,
I would give Usopp a devil fruit, that was
just recently revealed in the Manga. That
of marine admiral greenbull: The forest Zoan
devil fruit. We already know that during the
time skip Usopp has been getting really familiar
with different types of plants and uses them
elusively as his ammo. Much better than the
pocket fruit, this would give him infinite
ammunition, he could create a forest and switch
position freely within it to target his enemies
and as a logia user would be way less susceptible
to damage. And, as we know, he could actually
use his powers to drain the energy from his
enemies and heal himself, something that would
be especially important for Usopp, who always
takes a ton of damage.
Which now brings me to the man we’ve all
been waiting for. How broken can we make Zoro?
Oda gave Zoro Kaido’s fruit, which again
makes no sense at all. Yes this fruit is incredibly
overpowered and you can basically give it
to anyone and it makes them strong. Just look
at momonosuke. But how does turning into a
dragon complement Zoro’s incredible sword
skills, which is what makes him one of the
most powerful characters in the story in the
first place. Zack decided to give Zoro Kizaru’s
light logia fruit. A pick that i totally respect,
because that would have been my first idea
for Zoro as well. This fruit let’s Zoro
still use his sword skills and even create
light swords as we see with Kizaru himself.
Plus it gives him an incredible speed boost.
But i think we can make this even better.
One great pick for Zoro, just like for Sanji
would have been Robbin’s hana hana no mi,
giving Zoro more Sword arms to use. But it
does work way better for Sanji. He can sprout
legs and kick whereever he wants. Zoro can’t
duplicate his swords, so just having arms
in random spaces would be a waste. Alternatively
Zoro could eat the Spider devil fruit and
use that for more arms like this marine guy
does and use poison attacks. But that’s
also not really like Zoro’s fighting philosophy.
Though then again you could argue that the
use of any devil fruit would go against zoro’s
bushido. So let’s say we hold a knife to
Luffy’s throat and tell Zoro to eat a devil
fruit or else. Which one is the best? I would
give Zoro none other than Blackbeard’s Yami
Yami no mi. It’s ability to nullify devil
fruit powers depends on direct contact with
the opponent, something that very much works
in Zoro’s favor as a swordsman. He is able
to drain opponents of their fruit ability,
so they have to face him straight on with
their own sword skills. This would make even
the most powerful devil fruit users powerless
against him. Just imagine Blackbeard with
Zoro’s sword fighting skills. Plus Zoro
could store things in his inside dimension,
working as infinite storage for the crew.
So let me know which one you would chose,
but in the meantime, make sure to check out
Zack’s original video right here and get
him over 100K.